This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Happy New Year, beautiful nerds. As is our tradition, we are launching 2023 with another batch of mini stories from the 99PI crew. We took an episode in between to send a big box of Christmas gifts to our Lola, but we wouldn't leave you with only one mini stories episode, of course not. We have stories of a liminal space, discombobulation, the wildest theme park in the world,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。美丽的书呆子们，新年快乐。按照我们的传统，我们将在 2023 年以 99PI 团队的一批全新迷你故事拉开序幕。中间我们抽出一集的时间，给我们的劳拉寄了一大箱圣诞礼物，但我们当然不会只留下一集迷你故事。我们有关于边缘空间、混乱、世界上最疯狂的主题公园的故事，
and the new family road trip game that will soon be sweeping the nation, called Should This Be a Street, or a Road? Stay tuned. Hey, Dillini Hall. What's your mini story about? Hey, Roman. My mini story is about a word that I learned recently, and the word is strode, which is a portmanteau of street and road. And are you familiar with the term? I am. I am familiar with the word strode, although I don't think I know everything. So let's, yes, let's talk about it. Okay, so for people who aren't, it describes a thoroughfare that basically tries to do two incompatible things at once. And in the process, it does both things badly.
还有即将风靡全国的全新家庭公路旅行游戏，叫做“这应该是一条街，还是一条公路？”请收听。嘿，迪莉尼·霍尔。你的迷你故事讲的是什么？嘿，罗曼。我的迷你故事讲的是我最近学到的一个词，这个词是 strode，它是 street（街道）和 road（公路）的混成词。你熟悉这个术语吗？我很熟悉。我很熟悉 strode 这个词，虽然我觉得我并不知道全部。所以，是的，我们来聊聊它吧。好的，所以对于不了解的人来说，它描述的是一条基本上试图同时做两件不相容的事情的主管道路。在这个过程中，它把这两件事都做得很糟。
We call this the futon of transportation. So this is Charles Morone. He's also known as Chuck. And he invented the term strode. If you think of a futon as being an uncomfortable couch that makes into an uncomfortable bed, a strode tries to do two things at once and it fails at both. It tries to be both street and road. I think most people think of those two things as synonyms, but so what is the difference
我们称之为交通工具中的折叠沙发。这位是查尔斯·莫龙。他也被称为查克。他发明了 strode 这个词。如果你把折叠沙发想象成一张让人坐着不舒服、变成床也让人不舒服的沙发，那么 strode 就试图同时做两件事，结果两件事都失败了。它既想成为街道，又想成为公路。我想大多数人认为这两者是同义词，那么，街道和公路有什么区别呢？
between a street and a road? Yeah, I mean, I think that's right. Most of us don't think of there being any difference, but Chuck is a former traffic engineer and he gave me his take on how he thinks about those two different things. So we'll start with how Chuck defines a road. A road is about moving things over distance at speed. Okay, so that's a road. It's all about getting
街道和公路之间？是的，我的意思是，我想这是对的。我们大多数人认为它们没有任何区别，但查克是一位前交通工程师，他向我谈了他对这两种不同事物的看法。所以我们从查克如何定义公路开始。公路是为了以速度将物资跨距离运送。好吧，这就是公路。它全关于快速将
people quickly from point A to point B. A street, according to Chuck, is a place like where people go to shop and hang out. In urban setting, a good street is one where you are going to experience more people outside of a vehicle than within a vehicle. You will have narrower streets, you will certainly have slow traffic, you will have lots of space for people. A good street is one that prioritizes being in the place over getting through the place. Okay, I get it.
人们从 A 点带到 B 点。根据查克的说法，街道是一个人们去购物和闲逛的地方。在城市环境中，一条好的街道是指你在车外遇到的人多于在车内遇到的人。你的街道会更窄，交通肯定会很慢，会有很多供人们活动的空间。一条好的街道是优先考虑“身处该场所”而不是“穿过该场所”。好吧，我明白了。
So if you take the features of a road and you mash them together with the features of a street, you get a strode, which is a place where traffic is moving relatively fast. And there's a lot of development and people. Yeah, that's right. It's like an unholy combination of the two things. Strode usually have multiple lanes of traffic going in each direction. And then they're also lined with strip malls or big box stores or just business establishments that people are trying to get to. This is a place that when you look at it, the dominant feature of it is automobile mobility. The dominant feature is moving cars quickly. And in that case, it has a certain highway kind of sense to it.
因此，如果你把公路的特征和街道的特征混在一起，你就会得到一个 strode，这是一个交通流量相对较快的地方。这里有大量的开发项目和人群。是的，没错。这就像是这两者的一种邪恶结合。Strode 通常有双向的多条车道。然后它们的两旁还排布着购物中心、大型仓储超市，或者是人们试图前往的商业机构。这是一个当你看着它时，其最显著的特征是汽车机动性的地方。最显著的特征是快速移动汽车。在这种情况下，它有一种某种高速公路的感觉。
But appended to that is in this very almost freakish kind of way is this afterthought of humanity. So we'll put on the edge a little bit of place for people to walk. Maybe we'll throw in a bench here or a garbage can, because there might be somebody walking by with a Coke bottle they want to throw away. I love the way he puts that in afterthought of humanity. You'll get a garbage can if you're lucky.
但在这种感觉之上，以一种非常奇特的、几乎是怪异的方式，加上了这种对人性的事后诸葛亮般的考虑。所以我们会在边缘为人们留出一小块步行的地方。也许我们会扔进一张长椅或一个垃圾桶，因为可能会有人路过，手里拿着一个可乐瓶想扔掉。我喜欢他这种说法——对人性的事后考虑。如果你幸运的话，你会得到一个垃圾桶。
Exactly, yeah. I mean, that's their concession to people as a garbage can. And the way Chuck describes it, and I think the way most people who've driven down a strode experience it, is that because they're confused about their purpose, they're very stressful, like for everybody. If you're driving through these environments, they create a lot of tension within you because everything about the design is saying go fast. But everything about the, from the speed limit
没错，是的。我的意思是，那是他们对人类的妥协——一个垃圾桶。按照查克的描述，我想大多数在 strode 上开过车的人的体验是，因为它们对自己的目的感到困惑，所以对每个人来说压力都很大。如果你开车穿过这些环境，它们会在你内部产生很大的紧张感，因为设计的方方面面都在说开快点。但从限速到交通信号灯再到转弯交通的方方面面，
to the traffic signals to the turning traffic is slowing you down artificially from what the design is expressing to you. And so when you're in a car, you're like, why is it so crowded here? Like, why is it so stop and go? And then so when you're in a car, you're like, why is it so crowded here? Like, why is it so stop and go? And then, if you're a pedestrian or a bicyclist, you're just like, try not to die. 80% of the crashes that result in a fatality or a traumatic injury are on arterials and
都在人为地减慢你的速度，这与设计向你表达的意图相违背。所以当你在车里时，你会想，为什么这里这么拥挤？就像，为什么走走停停？然后，如果你是一个行人或骑自行车的人，你就会觉得，在努力活下去。80% 导致死亡或创伤性伤害的撞车事故都发生在主干道和
collectors, which essentially are our strobes. These are really dangerous environments and everybody can feel them when they're in that. And the wild thing is that even those strokes are dangerous and disorienting, and all the things Chuck has just described, they are everywhere in America. Like I've definitely had this experience where now that I know the word, strode, I cannot stop seeing them everywhere. It's like I have magic glasses on.
集散道路上，这本质上就是我们的 strode。这些是非常危险的环境，每个人身处其中都能感觉得到。最疯狂的是，即使这些 strode 是危险的、令人迷失方向的，以及查克刚刚描述的所有这些东西，它们在美国随处可见。就像我绝对有过这种经历，既然我知道了 strode 这个词，我就无法停止到处看到它们。就像我戴上了魔法眼镜一样。
And I think that's true for most people, especially here in the US. Yeah, yeah. So why are there so many strode to the US? What makes it happen here more than anywhere else? Well, it checks us that it has to do with the history of development in this country and how we came to be a country with a lot of sprawl. Back in the 1930s and 40s and 50s, we began to connect the country
我想这对大多数人来说都是真的，尤其是这里在美国。是的，是的。那么，为什么美国有这么多的 strode 呢？是什么让它在这里比其他任何地方都更多地发生？查克告诉我们，这与这个国家的开发历史以及我们如何成为一个拥有大量城市扩张的国家有关。早在 20 世纪 30、40 和 50 年代，我们就开始用庞大的道路网将全国连接起来。正如你所知，这是一笔巨大的投资，它是由土木工程师的工作推动的，并且是由对国家未来的极具田园诗般的想象所激发的。我们需要你出去花成百上千亿美元建设这个全新的系统来连接各个地方。我们要创建一个中产阶级，
with a vast network of roadways. It was, as you know, a huge investment, it was driven by the work of civil engineers, and it was motivated by a very idyllic picture of what the country could be. We need you to go out and spend billions and billions of dollars building this brand new system to connect places. We're going to create a middle class,
我们要创建郊区，我们要做到这一切，这样我们就不会滑回大萧条，并创造这个伟大的美国新版本。这就是宣传册上的内容。如果你把宣传册上的内容当真，比如暂且不管我们现在知道的所有负面影响，你就能明白为什么机动性和道路对于这种本质上属于郊的美国愿景如此重要——我们可以让更多的人去更多的岗位、更多的地方、更多的机会、更多的购物、
we're going to create suburbia, we're going to do all this so that we don't slide back into depression and so that we create this great new version of America. That was the marketing brochure. And if you that was the marketing brochure and if you just Take the marketing brochure on its face like hold off on all the downsides. We know about now You can see why mobility and roads were so important to this Essentially suburban vision of America we can get more people to more jobs, to more places, to more opportunity, to more shopping,
更多、更多、更多、更多、更多，我们真的可以推动我们的经济。因此，留给现代工程师的是一种机动性伦理。是的，当然，机动性真的很重要。就像通过州际公路系统连接全国基本上具有变革意义一样。是的，完全如此。
to more, more, more, more, more, and we can really drive our economy. And so what is handed down to modern engineers is an ethic of mobility. Yeah, and of course, the mobility is really important. Like it was generally transformative to connect the country through the interstate highway system. Yes, totally.
但对汽车机动性的重视也造成了我们现在的处境：我们许多人生活在既不算城市也不算城镇的社区中，而道路确实是这种郊区开发风格的基石。因此，一直以来，我们建造了大量极度依赖汽车的地方，它们将汽车置于人之上。是的。所以，我明白美国发展的历史导致了大量的
But the value placed on car-based mobility also created the situation we're in now where a lot of us live in communities that aren't quite cities and aren't quite towns and where roads are really the bedrock of that suburban development style. And so all the time, we've just built a lot of places that are very car dependent and just they prioritize cars over people. Yeah. So I get that the history of the development of the United States has led to a lot of
道路。但如果我们意识到道路是不好的，我想比查克更多的人意识到道路是不好的，比如为什么我们还要继续建造它们？我确信部分原因只是惯性。这就是我们长期以来的做法。我的意思是，查克描述了自己曾是一名年轻的交通工程师，基本上拿到了一本标准手册，里面全是关于如何修建街道的既定智慧，它们应该这么宽。当这些知识传授给我时，它是作为……
roads. But if we're realizing that roads are bad, which I think that more history of the development of the United States has led to a lot of roads. But if we're realizing that roads are bad, which I think that more people than Chuck have realized that roads are bad, like why do we keep building them? I'm sure part of it's just inertia. That's how we've done it for a long time. I mean, Chuck described being a young traffic engineer and basically being handed this manual of standards that are just like received wisdom about how you build streets and they should be this wide. And when this knowledge was given to me, it was given to me as, you know, you would give
任何神圣文本一样传授给我的。就像，这是我们的行为准则。这就是我们做事的方式。但还有另一个原因，那就是随着时间的推移，查克说，一套特定的开发理论在许多社区占了上风。基本上这个理论是这样的：如果你的城市或城镇有经济问题，那么它应该建造更多的公路，因为有大量的州和联邦资金来资助交通项目。我们在经济发展方面有问题。我们在创造就业机会方面有问题。
any sacred text. Like, here is our code of being. And this is, this is the way we do things. But there's another reason too, which is that over time, Chuck says, a certain theory of development has taken hold in a lot of communities. And basically the theory goes, if your city or town has economic problems, then it should build more roads because there's a lot of state and federal money to fund transportation projects. We have problems with economic development. We have problems with job creation.
我们在修复这个公园方面面临挑战，诸如此类，它们以这样或那样的方式都变成了交通挑战，因为钱就在那里。当他还是一个从事交通项目的工程师时，查克会向城市和城镇争辩说，他们对公路等事物的投资最终会得到回报。但随着时间的推移，他开始怀疑
We have challenges with getting this park fixed, you know, on and on and on, and they all become in one way or another transportation challenges because that's where the money is. And back when he was an engineer working on transportation projects, Chuck would make the argument to cities and towns that their investment in stuff like roads would eventually pay off. But over time, he came to doubt
这种财务论点是否甚至成立。比如，现在有很多研究表明，密集的市中心不仅更安全、更舒适，而且在财务上比郊区风格的 strode 开发项目要好得多。他们一次又一次发现的是，大萧条前的开发模式，即基本上围绕人们步行构建的模式，具有极高的财务生产力。换句话说，社区
that that financial argument was even true. Like, there's now a lot of research that shows that dense downtowns are not just safer and more pleasant. They're also a much better bet financially than suburban-style, strode development. What they have found time and time again is that the pre-great depression pattern of development, the pattern that was built around, essentially, people walking, that pattern has enormous levels of financial productivity. In other words, the community
从这些地方获得的税收收入超过了提供持续服务和维护的成本。另一方面，看起来更像大型仓储超市的开发项目，沿着广阔的 strode 延伸开来，并不是一个很好的投资。因为它们是以静态方式建造的，而不是动态方式，也不是随着时间推移而演变和改变的方式，所以当维护开始到期时，它们往往也会失去财务生产力。
is getting more tax revenue out of those places than it costs to provide ongoing service and maintenance. And on the other hand, development that looks more like big box stores, kind of strung along vast stretches of strode, that is not a great investment. Because they're built in a static way, not a dynamic way, not a way where they evolve and change over time, they also tend to lose their financial productivity when maintenance starts to come due.
哈，哦，这太有趣了。那么，如果你想让那种环境对每个人都更好一点，有没有办法“去 strode 化”？从许多方面来看，这现在正是查克的工作——他最终辞去了交通工程师的工作，因为他觉得他的工作正在损害他生活和工作的地区。他甚至写了一本名为《恢复期工程师的自白》的书。所以现在，他不再建造 strode 项目，
Huh, oh, that's so interesting. So is there any way to Unstrode a strode if you want to make that environment a little bit better for everybody? Well in many ways that is now Chuck's work like he eventually left his job as a traffic engineer because He felt like his work was harming the places where he lived and worked He even wrote this book called Confessions of a Recovery Engineer. So now instead of building Strodes' projects,
他已经成为密集城市主义的某种布道者。他四处奔走，向人们讲述如何建设更强大的城镇。他说，社区能做的最重要的事情之一，就是决定什么是街道，什么是公路。给我两个类别。我要么是在努力建设一个场所，要么是在努力快速移动车辆。我无法兼顾两者。我无法同时做到这两点，还能保证安全、富有成效、成为一个好的投资者。我必须二选一。给我一条公路，或者给我一条街道。然后，你知道的，一旦你决定某物是一条公路，就把它当成公路来对待。
he's become a kind of evangelist for denser urbanism. And he travels around the country, talking to people about how to build stronger towns. And he says that one of the most important things a community can do is just decide what is a street and what is a road. Give me two categories. I'm either trying to build a place or I'm trying to move vehicles quickly. I can't do both. I can't do both at the same time and have it be safe. Have it be productive. Have it be a good investor. I got to do one or the other. Give me a road or give me a street. And then, you know, once you've decided something is a road, treat it like a road.
不再试图诱导那种廉价的开发，不再对基础设施进行巨额投资。在这些地方，我们专注于快速移动车辆。我们专注于不以边缘化的方式迎合行人，我们真正专注于并将我们的资源投入到如何在这里非常快地移动汽车上。另一方面，当你决定某物是一条街道时，你要投资它，让它变得更好，让街道更安全、更慢，在设计时考虑行人和骑自行车的人，并鼓励沿街进行密集开发。这太有趣了，有点像强迫这种二元对立，让人们思考他们想从这些交通工具中得到什么。
No more trying to induce that cheap development, no more making huge investments in infrastructure. And in these places, we focus on moving vehicles quickly. We focus on not trying to accommodate pedestrians in a marginal way, we really focus and put our resources on how do we move cars really quickly here. And then on the other hand, when you decide something is a street, you invest in it and you make it better and you make the street safer and slower and you think about pedestrians and cyclists as you're designing it and you encourage dense development along the street. This is so interesting kind of forcing that binary to make people think about what they want out of
很难不使用街道和公路这两个词。太难了。太难了。把它变成一个循环的同义语反覆，不过不管怎样。在这段故事中制造挑战。不管怎样，这段故事中最大的挑战。但就像，你知道的，对于每天出行的人来说，思考这到底是用来做什么的，然后，然后，你知道的，然后为此进行设计，这真的很重要。完全同意。而且，你知道的，这回到了我之前提到的那个想法，即我现在有了这些神奇的 strode 眼镜，它能帮助我以这种新方式理解建成环境。作为一个例子，几天前，我在圣达菲的一条公路上开车。
these, you know, conveyances. It's hard not to use the word street and road. It's so hard. It's so hard. Making it like this circular totology, but anyway. Make a challenge with this story. but anyway, biggest challenge in this story. But like, you know, for people who travel every day, it really, you know, it's really important to think about what is this for and then, and then, you know, and then design for that. Totally. And, you know, it gets back to that idea that I have these magic strode glasses now, that like, help me understand the built environment in this new way. And just as an example, a couple days ago, I was driving down a road in Santa Fe.
它毫无疑问是一条公路。就像它载着我快速穿过城镇。两旁没有太多的开发项目或商店。没有多少红绿灯，也没有多少行人。它的目的非常明确。在上面行驶很愉快。当我开车时，我嘟囔着，这才是公路。
It was unambiguously a road. Like it carried me quickly across town. There was not a lot of development or stores on either side. Warned a lot of stoplights, weren't a lot of pedestrians. Its purpose was just very clear. And traveling on it was pleasant. And as I was driving, I muttered, now this is a road.
这让我和我一起坐车的丈夫非常困惑。他当时想，是的，这显然是一条公路。你在说什么？所以然后，他当时想，呃，是的，这显然是一条公路，你在说什么？所以然后，你知道的，我锁上了所有的车门，让他无法下车，并给他上了一课，讲了什么是公路以及它们为什么如此可怕，这是我如今最喜欢的话题。
Which was really confusing for my husband who was riding along with me. He was like, yeah, obviously this is a road. What are you talking about? So then, he was like, uh, yeah, obviously there's a road, what are you talking about? So then, you know, I locked all the doors, so he couldn't get out and gave him a lecture on roads and why they're horrible, which is my favorite topic of conversation these days.
嗯，我想这会成为许多人最喜欢的话题，就像当你到处开车时，就会想：街道还是公路？街道还是公路？这应该是什么？是的。哦，这太棒了。谢谢你，街道还是公路。这应该是什么？是的。这太棒了。谢谢你，罗曼。新年快乐。哦，新年快乐。
Well, I think it's gonna be a lot of people's favorite conversation, like when you're just driving around it's like street or road, street or road, what should this be? Yeah. Oh, this is awesome. Thank you street or road. What should this be? Yeah This is awesome. Thank you to me. Thank you Roman. Happy New Year. Oh, Happy New Year So I'm here with producer Jacob Maldonado Medina, who's name you've heard, but who's voice you haven't heard yet. So what are we going to talk about today, Jacob?
所以我和制作人雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳在这里，你们听过他的名字，但还没听过他的声音。那么雅各布，我们今天要聊什么呢？
So Roman, in my short time on the show, I think you guys have all realized that I've got a real fascination with amusement parks. They've noticed that pattern in your pitches. Yeah, I mean, I love all amusement parks. I love the big ones, your Disney's, your universals, but I'm especially fascinated by smaller parks. I think the more niche and weird it is, the more interested I am in it.
罗曼，在我做这个节目的短时间内，我想你们都意识到我对游乐园有着真正的迷恋。他们注意到了你提案中的这种模式。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢所有的游乐园。我喜欢大的，比如你们的迪士尼、环球影城，但我对较小的公园特别着迷。我认为越小众、越诡异，我就越感兴趣。
And in doing some research for a pitch, I got really obsessed with this one park called Asiana Napoles, and Puerto Trunfocolombia. So this park covers almost eight square miles and it's located four hours from Medellín on the Magdalena River. The area is honestly pretty secluded,
在为一个提案做研究时，我真的对一个叫做纳普利斯庄园（Asphalt Napoles，注：实为 Hacienda Nápoles）的地方着迷了，它位于哥伦比亚特龙福港。这个公园占地近八平方英里，位于距离麦德林四小时车程的马格达莱纳河畔。这个地区老实说相当偏僻，
which was a good thing for the previous owner of this land, Pablo Escobar. Oh, okay, so the land that this amusement park sits on today used to belong to, you know, world famous, notorious drug trafficker, Pavo Escabar. So tell me about how that happened. And I mean, what was he doing with those, you know, eight square miles? Yeah. So when this land belonged to Escabar, it sort of was his theme park. He was somebody who was not afraid to flaunt his wealth and spoil those around him, his family, his friends. Not only
这对这片土地的前主人巴勃罗·埃斯科巴来说是一件好事。哦，好吧，这个游乐园坐落的土地曾经属于世界闻名、臭名昭著的毒枭巴勃罗·埃斯科巴。所以告诉我这是怎么发生的。我的意思是，他用这八平方英里做了什么？是的。当这片土地属于埃斯科巴时，它某种程度上成了他的主题公园。他是一个不怕炫耀自己的财富并宠爱周围人（他的家人、朋友）的人。不仅
that, but he was so rich that he just truly didn't know what to do with all of his money, so he had to start spending some of it. So he built us in the Nappolus in the late 80s and the early 90s, and quite often he let the people from this running area convisity state and experience everything that he had to offer. Which was what? It was a lot of stuff. First of all, he had his house, which was a Spanish colonial style mansion. There was a racetrack. There were many pools, 27 artificial lakes, a bullfighting ring, a brothel, vintage cars, a sculpture park with some really ugly sculptures, including some dinosaur ones that are bizarre
如此，而且他太有钱了，以至于他真的不知道该怎么处理他所有的钱，所以他不得不开始花掉其中的一些。因此他在 80 年代末和 90 年代初建造了纳普利斯庄园，而且他经常让这个周围地区的人们参观庄园并体验他所能提供的一切。那是什么？有很多东西。首先，他有他的房子，那是一座西班牙殖民复兴风格的豪宅。有一个赛马场。有许多游泳池、27 个人工湖、一个斗牛场、一个妓院、老式汽车、一个雕塑公园，里面有一些非常丑陋的雕塑，包括一些看起来很怪异的恐龙雕塑，
looking, and of course, an airstrip because because your Pablo Escobar, you need it. Sure. And over the archway of the property, there was a life-size replica of the first plane Escobar used to smuggle drugs into the US. And on top of all that, there was not just one, but three zoos. Oh, three. That sounds like a lot. So why have three zoos when one would probably do? You think one would be enough, but Escobar had a real obsession with exotic animals. He had elephants, ostriches, giraffes, rhinos, antelope zebras, exotic birds, all of that. And most notably, he had four hippos, which we will get back to in just a minute. Okay. That's tantalizing, T's. Okay, so Escobar builds this giant playground for himself,
当然还有一条飞机跑道，因为既然你是巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，你就需要它。确实。在这处房产的拱门上方，有一个埃斯科巴用来走私毒品到美国的Тор-о-Том 第一架飞机的等比例复制品。最重要的是，不仅有一个，而且有三个动物园。哦，三个。听起来很多。那么，当一个可能就足够时，为什么要有三个动物园呢？你可能会认为一个就够了，但埃斯科巴对珍奇动物有着真正的痴迷。他有大象、鸵鸟、长颈鹿、犀牛、羚羊、斑马、珍奇鸟类，诸如此之类。最值得注意的是，他有四头河马，我们一会儿就会讲到。好吧。真让人心痒的悬念。好吧，所以埃斯科巴为自己建造了这个巨大的游乐场，
you know, exalting in his past exploits and also just fun stuff to do with him and his friends. And then, you know, they're all having fun in these, you know, three zoos and a bullfighting ring and brothel. I mean, what happens when it all comes crumbling down? So the good times are rolling until December of 1993. The killing of Colombian drug lord Pablo Escobar is sending a tougher message.
你知道的，陶醉于他过去的功绩中，也只是和他的朋友们一起做些有趣的事情。然后，你知道的，他们都在这三个动物园、斗牛场和妓院里玩得很开心。我的意思是，当这一切崩溃时会发生什么？所以好日子一直持续到 1993 年 12 月。哥伦比亚毒枭巴勃罗·埃斯科巴被杀，发出了一个更严厉的信息。
Mr Escobar was gunned down yesterday and Colombian authorities say its message to other drug lords is the surrender or you will be killed. So Pablo Escobar is shot and killed by the Colombian police. And after his death, there was a lengthy legal dispute over who owns this land, the government or Escobar's family. The government eventually won and they seized control of that land. Okay, so the Colombian government takes control of Escobar's park. What did they do with everything that was there?
埃斯科巴先生昨天被枪杀，哥伦比亚当局表示，这对其他毒枭的信息是：要么投降，要么被杀。所以巴勃罗·埃斯科巴被哥伦比亚警察开枪打死了。在他死后，关于这片土地归谁所有——是政府还是埃斯科巴的家人——展开了一场漫长的法律纠纷。政府最终获胜，并夺取了该土地的控制权。好吧，所以哥伦比亚政府控制了埃斯科巴的公园。他们对那里的所有东西做了什么？
They didn't really do much. Most of the animals that were there were moved to different zoos around the world, but the structures that sat on the land were mostly left abandoned. It was sort of a government's way of saying that they weren't going to honor the legacy of Escobar. But that all changes in 2007 when the government finally leased the land to a guy who wanted to build an amusement park. His name is over to Dan Martinez. To exploit this destiny as a destiny of a region to reactivate the economy of the region
他们其实没做什么。那里的绝大多数动物都被转移到世界各地的不同动物园，但土地上的建筑大多被废弃了。这算是政府的一种方式，表明他们不会纪念埃斯科巴的遗产。但这一切在 2007 年发生了变化，当时政府最终将这片土地租给了一个想要建造游乐园的人。他的名字是……交给达安·马丁内斯（Dan Martínez）。开发该地区作为地区命运的潜力，重新激活该地区的经济，
that had lost the security problems. In an interview with TV News Show, the National Desk, Martinez said that the mission was to take this region that was struggling because of security issues and reinvigorated. He was going to bring tourism back, essentially. There was a lot of violence that's run in the NAPA-LIS, when Escobar was there, which scared off visitors.
那里曾因安全问题而受损。马丁内斯在接受电视新闻节目“全国新闻台”采访时表示，其任务是夺回这个因安全问题而苦苦挣扎的地区并为其注入活力。他基本上是要把旅游业带回来。当埃斯科巴在那里时，纳普利斯庄园发生了大量的暴力事件，这吓跑了游客。
So, Martinez took over this property and took aspects of what was originally there, but kind of turned them on their heads to make this theme park. So, what do you mean by that? Well, the theme of this park is interesting and it's kind of all over the place. There's one section that's Jurassic Park theme, not licensed, of course. It's called Jurassic Adventure, and it's like a rainforest cafe at Jurassic Park. That part of the park kind of feels like a nod towards Escobar's own dinosaur sculptures I had when he owned the land. There's also a water park
所以，马丁内斯接管了这处房产，采用了最初存在的一些方面，但某种程度上把它们颠倒过来建造了这个主题公园。那你是什么意思？嗯，这个公园的主题很有趣，而且有点杂乱无章。有一个部分是侏罗纪公园主题的，当然没有获得授权。它叫做侏罗纪冒险，就像是侏罗纪公园里的雨林咖啡馆。公园的那个部分感觉有点像对埃斯科巴拥有这片土地时他自己的恐龙雕塑的致敬。还有一个水上乐园，
that's Pangea theme, which I don't totally understand that as a theme for a water park. Eskabara's original bullfighting ring is still there, but they converted it into an amphitheater, and then the park features tons of animals, but unlike Eskabara, the animals on the park now are rescues. So they're brought in from other zoos and the goal is to give them a comfortable place to spend the rest of their lives. So they're home to tigers, lions, elephants, kebibaras, monkeys. On top of that, there's a butterfly house, a bird, and reptile house. And of course, there are those hippos which I mentioned earlier. Here we go. Okay, hippo time. Tell me what happened with the hippos.
以泛大陆为主题，作为一个水上乐园的主题我不太理解。埃斯科巴最初的斗牛场还在那里，但他们把它改造成了一个露天剧场，而且公园里有大量的动物，但与埃斯科巴不同的是，公园里现在的动物都是被救助的。它们是从其他动物园引进的，目标是给它们一个舒适的地方度过余生。所以这里是老虎、狮子、大象、水豚、猴子的家园。最重要的是，这里有一个蝴蝶馆、鸟类和爬行动物馆。当然，还有我之前提到过的那些河马。我们来啦。好吧，河马时间。告诉我河马身上发生了什么。
After the government seized control of this land, the hippos that were escabars remained on the land because transporting hippos is really expensive and really hard to do, but they managed to escape from their enclosures and they reproduce rapidly. It's hard to say exactly how many hippos there are, but they're well over a hundred, and some of them still roam near the park. So there are signs posted all over warning people about wild hippos, and that might seem like a funny park-theming thing, but it's true there are wild hippos in the park. So there are signs posted all over warning people about wild hippos. And that might seem like a funny park theming thing, but it's true. There are wild hippos in the area. And this has become such an issue that in March of this year, the Colombian government declared hippos an invasive species. Scientists have predicted that their numbers could multiply
在政府控制了这块土地之后，埃斯科巴的河马留在了这块土地上，因为运输河马非常昂贵且非常难做到，但它们设法逃出了围栏并迅速繁殖。很难说到底有多少河马，但它们远超一百只，其中一些仍然在公园附近游荡。所以在各处都张贴了警告人们注意野生河马的标志，这可能看起来像一个有趣的公园主题设置，但事实是公园里确实有野生河马。所以在各处都张贴了警告人们注意野生河马的标志。这可能看起来像一个有趣的公园主题设置，但事实是该地区确实有野生河马。这已经成为了一个如此严重的问题，以至于在今年 3 月，哥伦比亚政府宣布河马为入侵物种。科学家预测，在未来十年内，它们的数量可能会激增
to over 700 in the next decade. And there are a lot of differing opinions on what the solution should be. And some of the offsprings of those original hippos now live at the theme park. So, Roman, I'm going to show you a picture of the park's mascot and I want you to describe her to me. Okay. So this is a hippo on two legs, bright magenta, like bright magenta with a crown. I would say it's a little femme hippo skirt, the necklace, really lovely. It's great. Great lashes, really, really big lashes. Exactly. Strong lashes. Yeah, so that's Vanessa the hippo. She is based on one of the actual offspring of Escobar's original hippos who lived on the land. Vanessa was rejected by the larger group of hippos, which I found out a group of hippos is called a bloat of hippos.
到 700 多只。对于解决方案应该是什么，有很多不同的意见。那些最初河马的一些后代现在住在主题公园里。所以，罗曼，我要给你看一张公园吉祥物的照片，我想请你描述给我听。好吧。所以这是一只两腿站立的河马，亮品红色的，就像带有王冠的亮品红。我想说这是一只穿着裙子、戴着项链的可爱女河马，真的很可爱。太棒了。睫毛很棒，真的非常非常大的睫毛。没错。浓密的睫毛。是的，那是河马瓦妮莎。她是以埃斯科巴原初河马的一只真实后代为原型的，那只河马曾住在庄园里。瓦妮莎被更大的河马群体排挤了，我发现河马群被称为一团河马（a bloat of hippos）。
Okay. She was rejected. And so she's been raised at the park by humans and is very social. You can meet Vanessa, feed her carrots, and she'll respond to her name. And she's got her own blog, which I'll be honest, it's a little bit lackluster. There's not much going on. It's a few pictures and all the loremipsa is still on the blog. So independent of the aggressive evokes that might be taken over Columbia, what have they done with the Escobar part of this area? Like if they kind of erased it, are they preserving it and presenting it?
好吧。她被排挤了。所以她在公园里由人类抚养长大，非常具有社交性。你可以见到瓦妮莎，喂她胡萝卜，她对自己的名字会有反应。她有自己的博客，说实话，有点乏善可陈。没有太多动态。只有几张照片，博客上仍然留着所有的占位文本（Lorem Ipsum）。因此，撇开可能接管哥伦比亚的具有侵略性的河马不谈，他们对该地区的埃斯科巴部分做了什么？就像如果他们抹去了它，他们是在保护它还是在展示它？
Like what happens to all things Escobar when it comes to this amusement park? The focus of the park definitely is not Escobar. In fact, it's sort of intentionally hidden, but there is a place on the property that's vaguely named the Memorial Museum. Most of the structures that Pablo Escobar built have crumbled except for pieces of the mansion. So this is one of the few places across the whole 3,700 acre park that openly acknowledges Escobar's connection with the property. And if you go to their website, you've even got a dig to find that. It's not one of the main listed attractions. It's no Vanessa. No, it's no Vanessa.
当涉及到这个游乐园时，所有关于埃斯科巴的东西都怎么了？公园的重点绝对不是埃斯科巴。事实上，它有点像被有意隐藏了，但在庄园里有一个地方被模糊地命名为纪念博物馆。巴勃罗·埃斯科巴建造的大多数建筑除了豪宅的残片外都已经坍塌了。所以这是整个 3700 英亩公园中极少数公开承认埃斯科巴与这处房产有联系的地方之一。如果你去他们的网站，你甚至必须深入挖掘才能找到它。它不是主要列出的景点之一。它不是瓦妮莎。不，它不是瓦妮莎。
It doesn't get a blog. No. This is where you can see a few of Escobar's vintage cars park outside. These are all like burnt out and riddled with bullet holes. And inside the remains of the mansion is a museum commemorating some of the journalist and politicians Escobar had killed. It's meant to sort of be an anti-crime museum. This is partially an effort by the government to make sure that the life of a narco trafficker isn't glorified.
它没有博客。不。在这里你可以看到外面停着几辆埃斯科巴的老式汽车。这些车都烧焦了，布满了弹孔。在豪宅遗迹内部是一个纪念埃斯科巴杀害的一些记者和政客的博物馆。它旨在成为某种反犯罪博物馆。这部分是政府为了确保毒枭的生活不被美化而做出的努力。
Because with shows like narcos that really show the glamour of the drug trade, the government's actively working against that. It's definitely a weird juxtaposition with the pink hippo and a tutu, but I think it'd be equally weird if they just didn't acknowledge Escobar at all. Right, right.
因为有了像《毒枭》这样真正展现毒品贸易魅力的节目，政府正在积极对抗这一点。这绝对与穿着芭蕾舞裙的粉红河马形成了一种奇怪并置，但我认为如果他们根本不承认埃斯科巴，同样会显得很奇怪。对，对。
It's a pretty tricky line to walk, but the park really isn't meant to be Escobar themed. It's just a theme park on what used to be Escobar's land. Wow. And the best example of this is that archway at the entrance of the land. So when Escobar lived there, he had that replica of his plane, a little sessana. And then when Asiananapolis theme park took over, they took the plane and they painted zebra stripes onto it, so to add that like safari seam right in the entrance, but it was still too connected to Escobar. People who were watching narcos would come to
这是一条相当棘手界限，但这个公园并不是要以埃斯科巴为主题。它只是一个建在曾经是埃斯科巴土地上的主题公园。哇。最好的例子就是土地入口处的那个拱门。所以当埃斯科巴住在那里时，他有他那架飞机的复制品，一架小塞斯纳。然后当纳普利斯庄园主题公园接管时，他们把飞机拿下来，在上面画了斑马条纹，以便在入口处增加那种野生动物园的主题，但它与埃斯科巴的联系还是太紧密了。看《毒枭》的人会来
take a picture with the iconic archway in plane because it reminds them of who the park belonged to. And so eventually the park took that plane down and knocked that whole archway over. The plane was brought into the park so that it's not the first thing you see when you get there. So you can still find those hints of Eskabara, but you've got to look for them in the park. Wow. You definitely found one of the most unusual amusement parks in the history of the world, probably. I think so. What a series of conundrums that they have to solve, not least of which, is the wild hippos that have now taken over parts of Columbia.
在标志性的拱门和飞机前拍照，因为它让他们想起这个公园属于谁。所以最终公园把那架飞机拿了下来，并把整个拱门推倒了。飞机被搬进了公园内部，这样当你到达那里时它就不是你看到的第一样东西。所以你仍然可以找到那些埃斯科巴的痕迹，但你必须在公园里寻找它们。哇。你绝对找到了世界历史上最不寻常的游乐园之一，大概吧。我想是的。他们必须解决一系列难题，其中绝不轻松的就是现在已经接管哥伦比亚部分地区的野生河马。
I mean, what an amazing place connected to a really horrible man. Yeah, it's an interesting repurposing of the land, for sure. Yeah, yeah. Well, this is Fascinated South Jacob. Thanks so much for bringing us the story, and it's a pleasure tourposing of the land for sure. Yeah, yeah. Well, this is Fascinese uptick. Thanks so much for bringing us the story. And it's a pleasure to have you on the show. Thanks, Rowan. We'll go down a dark alley with Kurt Colstead after this.
我的意思是，这是一个与一个真正可怕的人相连的令人惊叹的地方！是的，这绝对是对这片土地的一个有趣的重新利用。是的，是的。好吧，这真是太迷人了，雅各布。非常感谢你给我们带来这个故事，很高兴你能来到这个节目。谢谢你，罗曼。接下来我们将和库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）一起走进一条黑暗的小巷。
Earlier this year, 9 and I PIs, Colestead co-produced a three-part series on vernacular architecture that celebrated our 500th and 501th, 500 first and 500 second episode. And in those episodes, our staff and friends this show, they shared their personal experiences with various building types that were near and dear to them. And in the end, we just had too many great stories. And so Kurt saved one for later. I did. And for anybody who's ever wondered how I got to be
今年早些时候，9% Invisible 的科尔斯特德与人联合制作了一个关于本土建筑的三部分系列节目，以此庆祝我们的第 500 集、第 501 集和第 502 集。在这些节目中，我们的员工和节目的朋友们分享了他们对各种对他们至关重要且亲近的建筑类型的个人经历。最后，我们有太多精彩的故事了。因此，库尔特留了一个以后再说。我是留了。对于任何想知道我是如何变成
this incredibly nerdy urbanist that I am today, well, there's also a little bit of my origin story baked into this tale. It starts in Old Beijing, a part of China's capital city, and I was in the country to travel with my father who was working there, and we saw all of these amazing sights, but to me, Old Beijing was the most fascinating place we visited. And I take it from the name Old Beijing, it's Old. Oh yes, yes. For starters, it's very, very old.
今天这个超级书呆子气的城市规划师的人，好吧，这个故事里也烘焙了一点我的起源故事。它始于老北京，中国首都的一部分，我当时去那里旅行是为了陪在那儿工作的父亲，我们看到了所有这些令人惊叹的景象，但对我来说，老北京是我们参观过的最迷人的地方。我从“老北京”这个名字推断，它很老。哦，是的，是的。首先，它非常非常老。
And it's this area that's defined in large part by these ancient Houtong alleyways, which are mostly car-free today, and are dense and bustling with city life, but in this cozy and comfortable way that I really loved. And these already narrow alleys in turn branched off into even narrower paths, like veins and arteries, forking into capillaries. But when I started to wander down one of these smaller paths, this old woman appeared at a doorway
这是一个很大程度上由这些古老的胡同小巷定义的地方，今天它们大多是无车区，密集而充满城市生活的气息，但却带有一种我非常喜欢的舒适惬意的方式。这些本来就很窄的小巷反过来又分支成更窄的小径，就像静脉和动脉分叉成毛细血管一样。但是当我开始在其中一条较小的小径中漫步时，一个老妇人出现在一个门口
and she waved me off, because apparently I'd crossed some kind of invisible threshold between public and private space. It was this line that only she could see, and to my dad and my brother, it was just a curiosity. But to me, I mean, you know me, I was very deeply intrigued and I had to know more. Like I can't let this go.
她挥手让我离开，因为显然我越过了某种公共空间和私人空间之间的无形阈值。那是只有她才能看到的线，对我和我弟弟来说，这只是一种好奇心。但对我来说，你知道我的为人，我深感着迷，我必须了解更多。就像我不能放过这个。
Of course not. No, me of all people know, no way. And so after the trip, I started digging into the long history of who tongs to try and understand what my transgression had been, right? And I learned a lot about the history of these who-tongs along the way, which have changed a lot over time. Way back in the 13th century, who-tongs were simply these utilitarian alleyways that helped Beijing function. I mean, it makes sense a lot of cities have alleyes. I mean, so what
当然不能。不，我比任何人都清楚，没门。所以在这次旅行之后，我开始深入研究胡同的悠久历史，试图了解我当时究竟触犯了什么，对吧？在这个过程中，我了解了很多关于这些胡同的历史，它们随着时间发生了很大的变化。早在 13 世纪，胡同就只是帮助北京运转的实用主义小巷。我的意思是，这很合理，很多城市都有小巷。我的意思是，胡同有什么不同或特殊之处？
was different or specific about who-tongs? Historically, it was less that the alleyes themselves were different, more that the architecture they served was, because the city's residential vernacular was dominated by this special kind of courtyard home that took up a lot of space. We're talking about huge wall-to-states, each containing multiple houses arrayed around this central open space. And so unlike alleys, in the way that we think of them running behind blocks, these ran behind blocks between blocks
从历史上看，与其说是小巷本身不同，不如说它们服务于的建筑不同，因为该市的住宅本土建筑由这种占用大量空间特殊四合院主导。我们谈论的是巨大的围墙大院，每个大院都包含围绕这个中央开阔空间排列的多座房屋。因此，与我们认为位于街区后方的那些小巷不同，这些小巷位于街区之间、
because what they were serving was these huge courtyard complexes. Right, okay, I see. So you have this open space. There's lots of freestanding buildings between them. These alleys, they're not in a grid necessarily. They're basically like roads to access all these different spaces within these courtyard systems. Exactly.
因为它们服务的正是这些巨大的四合院建筑群。好吧，我明白了。所以你有了这个开阔的空间。它们之间有很多独立建筑。这些小巷不一定呈网格状。它们基本上就像通往这些四合院系统内所有不同空间的道路。完全正确。
And these Hutong serve other walled structures too. Like this courtyard approach I'm talking about was used for palaces and markets and temples and all kinds of other architecture. And in a way, the city itself was kind of like a giant courtyard mega complex because it had its own walls and watch towers. But then in the early 1900s, everything changed.
这些胡同也服务于其他带围墙的结构。就像我谈到的这种四合院方法被用于宫殿、市场、寺庙和各种其他建筑一样。在某种程度上，城市本身就像一个巨大的四合院超级建筑群，因为它有自己的城墙和瞭望塔。但随后在 20 世纪初，一切都改变了。
Yeah, I would say so. I mean, you talk about like the fall of, you know, the last, you know, Chinese dynasty, politicals, everything changed. Yeah, I would say so. I mean, you talk about the fall of the last Chinese dynasty, political struggles, you got revolutions, you got modernization, urbanization. You're like, I can imagine that all of that had an impact on the capitalist city as well. Yeah, just a little bit. And so the built environment was reshaped really quickly
是的，我这么认为。我的意思是，你谈到诸如……最后一个中国朝代的灭亡，政治斗争，一切都变了。是的，我这么认为。我的意思是，你谈到最后一个中国朝代的灭亡，政治斗争，你有革命，你有现代化，城市化。你会想，我能想象所有这些对首都城市也有影响。是的，只是一点点。因此，随着你刚才提到的所有这些力量，建成环境被非常迅速且非常剧烈地重塑了。
and really dramatically with all of those forces you just mentioned. And to begin with, they started pulling down those walls around the city so that Beijing could grow outward. But of course, there's also this growing population inside the city. And I'm guessing that the courtyard homes and all that extra space was pretty tempting
首先，他们开始拆除城市周围的城墙，以便北京能够向外生长。但当然，城市内部的人口也在不断增长。我猜，当涉及到为人们开发新的居住和生存空间时，四合院和所有这些额外的空间是非常具有诱惑力的。哦，是的。因此，为了腾出空间，正如可以预料的那样，其中一些四合院被简单地拆除了，留下了一片空地用于建造更密集、更高的建筑，但其中许多只是被填满了。那么填满是指什么？
when it came to developing some new spaces for people to live and exist. Oh yeah. And so to make room, some of these courtyard houses were predictably just demolished, which left an empty site for denser, taller architecture to be built up, but a lot of them were just filled in instead. So filled in and what's that?
嗯，就像我刚才说的那些开阔的庭院，挤满了这些新建筑。但是，当然，沿着这些大型住宅街区延伸的胡同。好吧，突然之间，前庭院内部有了他们再也无法触及的建筑。所以他们基本上必须修建更多的胡同来连接内部的一切。
Well, as in those open courtyards I was talking about, became packed with these new buildings. But of course, the Houtang alleys running alongside these big residential blocks. Well, suddenly there were buildings inside of the former court yards that they couldn't reach anymore. So they basically had to make more Houtongs to reach everything inside.
正如我刚才所说，那些开放式四合院挤满了这些新建筑。当然，胡同沿着这些大型住宅区延伸。突然之间，原先四合院内部建起了建筑，他们再也无法触及。因此，他们基本上不得不修建更多的胡同，以便通往里面的所有地方。
And was this like a planned thing? Or does it kind of happen? I mean, as far as I could tell, it really wasn't. It was pretty organic. And residents just sort of negotiated this mishmash of remaining voids so that everybody could have at least some narrow path into and out of the complex to get to their house. And these new paths that were formed in these courtyards aren't exactly public spaces,
这是一种有计划的安排吗？还是自然发生的？我的意思是，据我所知，这真的不是有计划的。它非常自然。居民们只是协商利用了这些剩余的杂乱空间，以便每个人至少都有一条狭窄的小路可以进出大楼回家。在这些庭院中形成的新小路并不完全是公共空间，
but they aren't exactly private spaces either. They're liminal spaces. Or at least that's I hope why I was shoot away from one when I was an old Beijing. Right. So you passed this threshold where this bigger alley became a smaller alley that basically became like the pathway to someone's door, essentially. And there was no marking to delineate that, but that's exactly what it was.
但它们也不完全是私人空间。它们是过渡空间。或者至少我希望这就是为什么我在老北京时被赶走的原因。对吧。所以你越过了这个界限，更大的胡同变成了更小的胡同，基本上变成了通往某人家门的路。没有任何标记来划分这一点，但事实确实如此。
And of course, for me, all of this was really charming and interesting, but that's always the case for an outsider. And things could be different for people who live there. And when I was researching this afterward, I learned that in some cases, for example, a large number of these very small households don't have enough space to have their own bathroom. And so they have to share a communal one. But some dwellings alongside the Hutongs are still quite expansive and luxurious, too. Like in most places, there's a huge range in terms of the quality of life
当然，对我来说，这一切都非常迷人和有趣，但局外人总是这样看的。对于住在那里的人来说，情况可能就不同了。当我事后研究这件事时，我了解到在某些情况下，例如，大量这些非常小的住户没有足够的空间拥有自己的浴室。所以他们必须共用一个公共浴室。但胡同旁的一些住宅仍然相当宽敞和豪华。就像大多数地方一样，生活质量
and the cost of living there. Yeah. I mean, so you researched all this after the fact, you didn't know this at the time. I mean, but what made you go down a Hutong to begin with? Yeah, no, it was so many things. There were all of these little grocery shops and cafes and bars, and there were residents
和生活成本存在巨大差异。是的。我的意思是，所以你是在事后才研究这一切的，你当时并不知道。我的意思是，是什么让你一开始就走进了一条胡同？是的，不，原因太多了。到处都是小杂货店、咖啡馆和酒吧，还有居民
just relaxing and playing chess and sipping tea. There's like laundry strung up above the Hootongs, bikes leading up against the walls, and basically any niche that hadn't been filled by something else had plants in it. And so it was like the closeness and the density of this space pushed everything out into a shared public sphere. And again, it's easy for me to say, oh, that's cozy rather than cramped because I don't have to live my life.
在悠闲地聊天、下棋、品茶。胡同上方挂着晾晒的衣服，自行车靠在墙上，基本上任何没有被其他东西占用的角落都摆满了植物。因此，这个空间的紧密和密集将一切都挤到了一个共享的公共领域中。再说一次，我说“哦，这很温馨而不是局促”很容易，因为我不必亲自去过这种生活。
And I should also mention that the meaning of the word Hutong itself has evolved as well, much like these physical spaces that we're talking about. So these days, Hutong can still mean alleyway, but it's also become a term for the neighborhoods that grew up around these old Alex. That makes sense. So these days, Houton can still mean alleyway, but it's also become a term for the neighborhoods that grew up around these old Alex. That makes sense.
我还应该提到，“胡同”这个词本身的含义也发生了演变，就像我们正在讨论的这些物理空间一样。所以如今，“胡同”仍然可以指小巷，但它也成为了围绕这些老巷子发展起来的街区的代名词。这就说得通了。所以如今，“胡同”仍然可以指小巷，但它也成为了围绕这些老巷子发展起来的街区的代名词。这就说得通了。
Just naming something after the defining feature, like I don't know, her most a beach or something like that. Like the whole thing is not a beach. But, no, but it gives its character and that's what people think of when they think of the place. And for me, as an urbanist, I really love these Houtons. They're dense and walkable with all this street life
就像用最具代表性的特征来命名一样，比如说，我不知道，海滩之类的地方。整个地方并不全都是海滩。但是，不，但这赋予了它独特的个性，这也是人们想到这个地方时的第一印象。对我来说，作为一名城市规划师，我真的很喜欢这些胡同。它们密集且适合步行，充满了街头生活
and all these shops. And you could say that they're right up my alley. No, you could not say that. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, years, we might have trained people to see the who-tongs and not the great wall. Or do both. Yeah, I'd like to think so, yeah. It's very much, you know, always read the plaque, take a minute, look closely at the thing. It's so easy to overlook, and it's so hard to miss the great wall of China.
和各种店铺。你可以说这正合我意。不，你不能这么说。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，尼尔，多年来，我们可能已经训练人们去看到胡同而不是长城。或者两者兼顾。是的，我希望如此。很多时候，你知道，总是去读一读牌匾，花上一分钟，仔细看看那个东西。它太容易被忽视了，而中国的长城又是那么显眼。
Exactly. Well, thank you for, you know, another year of helping us see the things that are pretty easy to mess with, I appreciate it. Oh, will you too, Roman? 99% invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, Jacob Moltenado Medina, and Kirk Holstead, sound mix by Martin Gonzales, music by our director sound Swansea El. The rest of the team is Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Lashmodon, Jason De Leon, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his Vologa was created by Stefan Lawrence.
确实如此。好吧，谢谢你，你知道，又一年帮助我们看到那些很容易被忽略的事物，我很感激。哦，也谢谢你，罗曼？本周的《99%隐形》由德兰尼·霍尔、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳和柯克·霍尔斯特德制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺西·埃尔创作。团队的其他成员包括维维安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、拉什莫顿、杰森·德·莱昂、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》由斯特凡·劳伦斯创立。
We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join the discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI at Ork. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的美丽地方。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI at Org）。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的所有往期节目
at 99PI.org. You're listening to a Stitcher podcast from Siria Sexam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99PI.org。您正在收听的是 SiriusXM 旗下的 Stitcher 播客。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。